[Music]
good to go yeah let's do it
you remember everyone Thanos snapped
away five years ago we're just bringing
them back to now today don't change
anything from the last five years good
everybody comes home
[Music]
[Applause]
take it off wait Bruce are you okay
talk to me banner
[Music]
everybody it's Charlie this is going to
be my video for the secret time-travel
easter egg that was in avengers endgame
that people have been talking about
recently I got a lot of requests in the
last week people have been talking about
it someone on the Avengers mysteriously
traveled to the Year 2988
as per this console this has the three
different time vectors for the places
through the quantum realm that the
Avengers teams travel to to steal the
Infinity stones it's a really small
detail that's going to be a much bigger
thing during Marvel phase four the
origin of the Easter Egg is so this
would be my Young Avengers video about
why the Russos are teasing this way off
Marvel phase four Marvel phase five
we're doing that Avengers endgame
blu-ray giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
best Marvel phase 4 theory on the video
I believe the questions about this
started on reddit where people were
asking what this 2988 date meant a lot
of people thought that it might be a
mistake that got left into the
theatrical cut even though they spend
hundreds of millions of dollars making
these films there's an army of people
working on them there's still stuff that
falls through the cracks so you'll still
find little errors every once in a while
in Marvel movies either a technical
error or an editing error where there's
someone in the background of a shot
doing something that they're not
supposed to and they just didn't remove
it in post-production
but this 2988 in 2009 date both got left
in on purpose also within this is the
2009 Easter Egg but that's not
necessarily a Young Avengers Easter Egg
the way that the 2988 one is during
their commentaries recently the Russos
and the writers talked about the
complicated process of how they came up
with a lot of their time travel Easter
eggs and plans they always want to try
and weave in as many Easter eggs as
possible and set things up for Marvel
phase 4 Marvel phase 5 future movies
they do that in every big Avengers movie
but they didn't want to be so on the
knows about things that it would hurt
their main goal of bookending the
original six Avengers stories that's why
there was no traditional post-credit
scene it was sort of an Iron Man tag at
the end credits but it's not the type of
post credit scene you would expect from
a Marvel movie
so the 2988 time-travel plot started out
when they were picking alternate
versions of the teams which Avengers
would go to which time period there were
three different teams on this console
you can see the different vectors
unquote through the quantum realm vector
one is May 2012 that's the release date
of the first Avengers movie that was
Iron Man Captain America Hulk in ant-man
vector 2 is January 29 88 that's Hawkeye
black we know nebula in war machine
obviously they did not go to 2988 as far
as we saw they went back to 2014 vector
3 is November 2009 that was Thor in
rocket but obviously they went back to
Thor the dark world that was November
2013 like I said that's not necessarily
a Young Avengers Easter Egg but it's
just part of this larger story of how
they changed a lot of the plot in what
it was originally supposed to be the
2988 was just an alternate version of
events they were gonna send a team to a
different time period and it was
actually going to be 2988 BC not the
future is a lot of people believe
because it doesn't have an ad or a BC
here so you're kind of left to wonder
but originally the idea was is that they
would send a thor based team back to
2988 on earth to look for the reality
stone when his grandfather Bor trapped
it in that special device in the center
of the earth
the brilliant audible thing about this
period in history is the king the
conqueror was ruling over Egypt so the
thing about King the conquer really big
Young Avengers villain time-travel
villain probably the biggest time-travel
villain in one of the earliest Avengers
villains that they face in the comics
fun fact though he debuted during
Fantastic Four number 19 as a character
called Rama Tut and then later a comic
sort of integrated that into his
timeline that was his previous persona
when he was ruling over ancient Egypt
during this period when the Avengers
would have come back to look for the
reality stone he didn't become an
Avengers Vil until that next year in
Avengers number 8 but back in the
mid-60s in that first run of Avengers
there were a lot of King time-travel
stories so he's a huge deep cut
time-travel Avengers villain the
Avengers are finally time-traveling what
a great time to include an Easter Egg
for King the Conqueror and future Young
Avengers time travel what happened was
as they started to change who was on
each team and then when they would go
back to and eventually they got to the
idea that they would do Thor during Thor
the dark world and because his PTSD
thick Thor
they added the plot with his mother
because the people that wrote Avengers
endgame also wrote Thor the dark world
which is one of the lowest rated Marvel
films so they took that as an
opportunity
to sort of refresh the plot of that and
retro actively make it a little bit
cooler and fix some of those character
arcs particularly thorns mother but then
you asked if they changed the plot of
the movie early on a couple different
times why didn't they then change the
date on the console before the movie
came out because that is a really small
detail and really easy for them to fix
in post-production
the answer is that it's all in service
of setting up future jumping off points
for Marvel phase for Marvel phase 5
movies little things that they don't
really address during the course of the
movie like you're talking Oh Denise
Triggs
things that you just brush past and then
later people start asking questions like
hey wait a minute why did we just see
the Infinity Gauntlet in Odin's vault at
the beginning of phase 1 but the Russos
themselves aren't involved in the
development of Marvel phase 4 Marvel
phase 5 films they've talked about
coming back to do a Wolverine film they
even talked about coming back to do an
Avengers Secret Wars film that was
actually a fun clip that was during
infinity war before they had all the Fox
characters locked down been so focused
on these movies though that we haven't
been thinking beyond them I will say
though that that Fox Steel goes through
with Disney there's a lot a lot more
characters to work with us and be
interesting to do something like Secret
Wars so the idea is they just leave this
there for future movies future directors
future riders to pick up on in any way
that they want Kevin Feige has already
been very clear that they've talked
about doing a young avengers project
they didn't say whether it would be a
movie or whether it would be one of
those Disney Plus series but I've
already done a couple videos about all
the Young Avengers characters that they
already have in the universe you already
have Cassie Lang's stature that they
clearly set up because she's still going
to be a teenager whenever they get to
the plot of ant-man in the wasp part 3
you have Kate Bishop you also have the
Harley Keener iron lad he said that he
really wants to come back and play iron
lad they've got Sheree who's the exact
same age as spider-man in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and he's about 17
during the events of spider-man far from
home but as for when we might actually
see a Young Avengers project that would
have to be during Marvel phase 5 now
just based on the fact that they plotted
all the movies and TV shows they're
gonna do during Marvel phase 4
spider-man 3 is still a bit of a
question mark they're gonna do it it's
just that Sony still wants to promote
spider-man far from home it's still in
theaters it just made over a billion
dollars but they don't want people to
stop talking
far from home and that's exactly what's
gonna happen the minute they confirm
spider-man 3 so just think Young
Avengers sometime during Marvel phase 5
and that could last longer than Marvel
phase 4 Marvel phase 4 is only two years
but based on Kevin Feige comments during
the comic-con panel he said more like
the next five years including phase 4
and phase 5 so it sounds like phase 5
really will just be three years long
everybody post your Young Avengers
theories in the comments and what will
happen is is that Marvel d23 phase four
panel is happening next weekend they're
going to show off a couple trailers for
the Marvel phase four movies and maybe
small chance they talked a little bit
about what's going on during Marvel
phase five with Fantastic Four the x-men
the Deadpool characters everybody click
here for my breakdown of the Avengers
what if comic-con trailer footage and
click here for the boys season 2 trailer
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you